On est actuellement en Suisse dans une ville qui s'appelle Crans-Montana
Et on va tester un sport
un peu souvent sous-estimé :
c'est le curling
Evidemment je suis avec une team de choc
La dream team
Kemar
Yo, Kemar, talent web
Plus d'un million d'abonnés sur youtube
Titouche
Star de YouTube en devenir
T'as pas de buzz
J'ai pas de buzz !
Jhon Rachid
Wesh
J'suis un YouTubeur plutôt engagé
mais là aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie.
Et moi.
C'est la première fois de ma vie que je vois une piste de curling
Ces gens sont plutôt agés
Là on a le champion norvégien qui est là
Il est très en forme en ce moment
Il le joue !
C'est vraiment une position
qui met avant, hein
le corps humain
Là on enlève tous les cacas
sous la semelle
Est-ce que c'est important le choix du balai ?
Très important, super important si on veut bien nettoyer ouais
non c'est tous les même
Ah d'accord je pensais que c’était vrai moi
Voila donc ça c'est un balais de curling
Je découvre en, en live
Le bout, ça a l'air d'être mou
Le bâton, plutôt rigide
Et la taille s’arrête au téton
Voilà ! Taille téton
Énorme !
Là y'a eu de l'action, je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
C'est incroyable
Je vous explique en gros, la piste fait 45 metres
D'un cercle à l'autre
C'est un peu comme la pétanque
On dit que c'est la pétanque sur glace
Eh ouais?
Ah!
Ah
Le plus proche du centre euh, ben il gagne
Euh moi j'ai entendu dans un reportage
Que ça s'apellait la maison
C'est ça?
Voila bon
Je sais ça j'ai eu l'info
Donc ça c'est les Starting Blocks
*Beatbox*
1, 2, 3, Let's Go!
Ouai!
Allez
*Rires*
Voilà
C'est pas assez puissant ça
J'ai fait exprès
Voîla!
Oh purée!
Il y a une puissance
Ben alors eh, il faut jeter la pierre
Faut juste pas oublier un détail très important
Tu dois lâcher la pierre. Tu es pas respecté là
Je vais partir avec *Rires*  Tu sais à la base pour le curling il faut mettre ces chaussures là ? Sérieux ? Ouais. Faux!
On va mettre des glisses
C'est des chaussures pour que ça glisse
beaucoup plus, parce que on a envie de plus tomber
Comment se casser une jambe
En toute simplicité
Allez pousse ! Bien !
Attends! Je sens que je vais faire une petite carrière. J'ai pas le temps je fais le ménache depuis tout à l'heure
*Musique*
*Rires*
J'ai eu trop confiance en moi
Quelle humiliation sur glace
Oh il est très fort; oh ça vient du ghetto
Oh c'est gentil, oh la gentillesse
Ouais voilà
C'est beau ça
1m50, je suis quand même le premier à avoir fait
un truc qui ressemble à du curling
*Musique* *Bruit de canard*
Avec le bon cul
*Rires*, petit raie du ulc
Donc selon vous, qui est pour l'instant, le meilleur d'entre nous ?
Sans souci c'est ... la barbiche
*Rires* Montre moi! Pourquoi tu me montres pas ?
Et qui est le plus nul ?
Je ne ferrai pas de commentaires ... *Rires*
Eh bien joué
Yeah, beng beng
Bon maintenant objectif, traverser la piste sans
Se péter la gueule, c'est très bizarre d'avoir à la fois
un pied qui glisse à mort et un pied qui glisse
pas du tout, donc j'ai une démarche actuellement ridicule
Eh mais cet homme va tellement vite
*Bruitages* Alors
je vais me faire filmer pour réaliser
cette performance de balayage
yeah, c'est parti
*Musique* Euh Titouche? Ouais ?
ça ne se joue pas comme ça! Sérieux?
Donc le concept
C'est qu'on peut
Donner de l'effet a la pierre
Un peut comme au ping-pong
Là il n'y a pas d'effet, cet homme est nul
Est qu'on mettrai pas la caméra sur une pierre ?
Vous êtes prêts ? C'est parti!
Oh le boulet de canon
Putain, oh le con
Bon je ne vous cache pas que la moyenne d'age des joueurs ici
est plutôt élevée, on est sur une sorte de sortie de maison
de retraite. C'est pas celui là Norman!
Ah c'est pas ...? Mais non l'autre là bas au fond!
Ah
Equipe de quatre exclusivement. Ouais ou  tu peux jouer à trois contre trois
On peut tricher et être 45.
Donc là c'est le vrai match, qui contre qui ?
L'équipe des rouges
L'équipe des jaunes. Le duel est
parti, il sera sans pitié
Let's go. Allez je commence
Tu balayes donc. Je vais balayer ouais
Allez va balayer! Comme toute ma famille avant
Eh tout à coup il y a un gros enjeu, je suis stressé
C'est la compétition
Ah c'est joli, c'est pas mal hein
Balaye pas, balaye pas, balaye pas ! Contre balaye, contre balaye
Elle est encore là et tout le monde est cor-da
N*que le CSA
Tu as bien joué du premier coup, tu as posé les bases ça va être dur de
réagir après. Il faut dire que j'avais un balai professionnel
Un balai retor
Complètement adapté aux courbes de la piste
Ta réaction par rapport à mon premier coup très très lourd?
Ecoute, je vais répondre sur le terrain
OK c'est parti
Oh c'est pas degeu! Malheureusement très très lente
mais je compte sur mon balayeur, aller
tu peux l'avoir celle là
*Rires*  ah c'est une chute
On reste les favoris hein
Ah non c'est pas mal ça
Et je me rend compte que j'ai oublié d'aller sur la piste pour balayer
putain! Est ce qu'il y a des cris spéciaux,
qu'il faut crier quand on joue ? Des trucs connus ?
Non tu peux crier tout ce que tu veux
* cris incompréhensibles*
En avant pour la victoire
Non mais je hurle
non mais je hurle. Non mais
je hurle. Tu es au courant qu'ils ont deux pierres
dedans et qu'on a besoin de les dégommer
Sinon on ne gagne pas
La pression est totale
Allez prends la pierre
J'y arrive pas
La dernière pierre de la victoire Jhon Rachid
C'est maintenant
Il faut que je dégage les jaunes sinon on est dans la merde
Si je dégage pas à droite on est foutu
Non non non non
Allez balaye! gâche pas ma pierre
mais c'était une mauvaise pierre
C'est une très bonne pierre
* énervement des deux joueurs*
Calme toi Titouche ; attends c'est bon calme toi
Calme toi
Qu'est tu fais ? Oh c'est qu'un jeu wesh
Oh putain! Qu'est ce qu'il t'arrive ?
Viens là, viens là, viens là, viens là
viens là, viens là; arrêtez les mecs c'est qu'un jeu là
C'est qu'un jeu putain
Mais qu'est ce que
Arretez
Viens là je t'attends mon pote! Ce n'était que de la blague
faites vous un bisou allez. Ce n'était que de la comédie
C'était une bonne pierre quand même
Les rouges ont gagnés. Par contre il y a eu triche
ah s'il y a eu triche ...
Elle était là bas celle là
Les rouges ont gagnés donc moi et John Rachid
on a gagné alors en trichant
Ouaiiiis
Merci Yvan pour cette initiation  au curling
Grand plaisir. On a kiffé. Merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo sur le curling
Cette initiation
Ah ouiii, oauiiis
Mine de rien c'est un sport qui peut paraître tranquille mais
John il a ses doigts cassés
C'est extrême. Surtout ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'on croit que c'est nul mais c'est vachement bien
Si vous kiffez cette vidéo, la prochaine fois on testera
le criquet. Yeah. Ou le water polo
Ou jouer aux billes
Au revoir. Salut tout le monde